and i remember talking to uh
sasha stone about like he was trying to
get you to do a no jumper festival at a
certain point in time right there wasn't
that being tossed around we talked about
a little bit but i mean honestly
everybody in their [ __ ] mom has
talked to me about doing a festival
together or whatever and it's just such
a flooded market and like my whole thing
is like i'm not really trying to bring
anything to market as a business if it's
not gonna like
have a really unique
value proposition you know like when i
think about like
oh do another festival in l.a it's like
well there's already five million
[ __ ] festivals in la and if we're
gonna book artists we're basically gonna
end up booking all the same artists that
are playing all these other festivals
and they got exclusivity contracts so
we're not gonna be able to book a lot of
them and it's just
i don't know like people always want me
to do all the businesses that other
people that are basically like in my
position are doing like they see rolling
loud and they're like well couldn't you
do a rolling cloud it's like
maybe i could dedicate my life to trying
to like clone their business model but
they seem like they're doing a great job
well they also have been concert
promoters for you know
does the world like literally what they
they're doing a great job does the world
really need me to
do like another version of that same
thing and i respect it like i've seen
cole go through the whole thing and
doing the summer smash thing and he's
definitely building this like big
valuable ip out of that just doing this
concert
consecutively but like i never really
like wanted to do that